We lower inflammation help kidney function if I consume too much salt by legs and equals swell up for several days
I have rare and have rare occurrences in gout blood tests are normal except for by GFR your glomerular filtration rate
Which is 65?
Okay, so
Will low rate inflammation help kidney function?
Yes, will low rate inflammation help pretty much any every organ and tissue
As far as a person reacting to salt if they have too much salt there are legs and equals swell
That could be an issue with kidney issues
So obviously if your GFR is elevated we have kidney issues possible kidney damage at some points in time
And you and excretion of salt is an issue and that's causing you to retain your water
causing the legs swelling
So yeah, absolutely so tried and lastly the thing about salt person can have a salt sensitivity that's very
common with different autoimmune diseases there's different been different to labs I think I go into that
I think I shared some of the research in the autoimmune course about salt sensitivity
Why some people will have have salt sensitivity and salt increases their blood pressure and some people can eat salt
Like it's the you know
High on the food try go they don't have any issues whatsoever. It has to do with salt sensitivity
um
Some people have it is a trigger so we talk about autoimmune diseases
And looking for triggers salt can be a trigger so
the
The interesting thing with people that have salt as a trigger
For autoimmune issues if they if they take
fairly higher dose of potassium
With a salty meal that it doesn't cause a problem it basically negates that trigger that might be something to look into too
But definitely if you're holding water you want to make sure that you're helping increase kidney function
and
Health with detoxification pathways our course on detoxification the seventh phase in detoxification goes into that a little bit too
um
As far as gout goes so gaudy or arthritis isn't inflammatory arthritis so
um if
If you have issues with gout you know you have issues with inflammation
um and
You think oh, I got swelling so I have inflammation. Well you that's inflammation because of water retention
but definitely if you have if you have episodes of gout you have
uh
inflammatory
Processes that are going on so looking for triggers for that inflammation are going to be really important
They're trying to decrease the inflammation. It's going to be really important. I've had patients that have had um
you know
rheumatoid arthritis diagnosis these are gaudy arthritis of psoriatic arthritis the inflammatory arthritis diagnosis
And you just literally change their diet and their pain goes away
Um, it can take several months
But we've seen their pain just literally melt away and it's because you're you're eating foods that are inflammatory to your body
Go back to the what's inflammation and the gut is going to be systemic inflammation
If you're eating foods that are inflammatory they're gut. You're going to cause systemic inflammation
And um, and then you can get a diagnosis with all sorts of different names
and um, it gets down to cleaning up that person's diet cleaning up their gut
um, that's going to bring health to so many areas um
So that's what high high would highly recommend start there